bill cosby is out of prison today the
pennsylvania supreme court
overturned his 2018 sexual assault
conviction for drugging and assaulting
andrea constand at his home
in 2004. andrea constand is speaking out
after bill cosby's release from
prison and his sexual assault conviction
being overturned in a joint statement
with her attorneys
constand didn't hold back about the
dangerous repercussions
she believes this could have the
statement read
in part today's majority decision
regarding bill cosby
is not only disappointing but of concern
and that it may discourage those who
seek justice for sexual assault in the
criminal justice system
from reporting or participating in the
prosecution of the assailant
or may force a victim to choose between
filing either a criminal or civil action
according to documents obtained by e.t
on wednesday
because of an agreement cosby had with a
previous prosecutor
the pennsylvania court found that he
couldn't be charged in this case
in addition it was also ruled that
cosby's case cannot be prosecuted again
in the future cosby later shared this
message to his twitter account
i have never changed my stance nor my
story
i have always maintained my innocence
thank you to all my fans
supporters and friends who stood by me
through this ordeal
special thanks to the pennsylvania
supreme court for upholding the rule of
law
the ruling set off a firestorm of
responses in hollywood
but his former co-star on the cosby show
felicia rashad
faced her own barrage of criticism
following
this controversial tweet felicia wrote
finally a terrible wrong is being
righted
a miscarriage of justice is corrected
the backlash began immediately after
felicia's
public support of cosby's release hours
later she followed up with this tweet
which read i fully support survivors of
sexual assault coming forward
my post was in no way intended to be
insensitive to their truth
personally i know from friends and
family that such abuse has
lifelong residual effects my heartfelt
wish
is for healing